foreign
it's estimated that seat belts have
collectively saved over 1 Million Lives
making them one of the most cost
effective Public Health inventions ever
made these incredible devices can reduce
fatalities in car accidents by about
half yes their development and
implementation as standard equipment was
surprisingly Rocky for something that
seems so straightforward The Humble seat
belt is more sophisticated than you
might think
even though wearing a restraint in a
vehicle moving 100 kilometers per hour
may seem like common sense to us today
it took many years to convince the
driving public to buckle up a problem
that persists in many countries around
the world this ingenious device saves
lives and this is how it does it
[Music]
in 1903 race car driver Bernie Oldfield
became the first person to drive over
100 kilometers per hour he was all too
aware of the dangers he was subjecting
himself to a commissioned Leslie Leroy
Irvin another Daredevil of the 1920s to
develop a harness for his racing cars
Irvin had developed his own static line
parachute to jump out of airplanes and
in 1919 became the first American to
jump out of a plane and manually deploy
a parachute from a backpack in midair
the harness they came up with did not
catch on however despite its life-saving
potential it had a number of problems
first they were simply uncomfortable
which discouraged drivers and passengers
from wearing them then there was the
very real problem of seat belt syndrome
injuries directly related to wearing a
seat belt during a collision early seat
belts only went across the lap in the
event of a crash this rigid single
pointer restraint laying in line with
vital organs and the lumbar spine could
cause severe injuries
the prevailing thought at the time was
that it would be better to be ejected
from the vehicle which might catch on
fire or go underwater than to remain
inside of it during a crash by being
stopped forcefully by a thin piece of
fabric
despite Rising fatalities and injuries
during the rise of the automobile from
the 1920s and 1950s the general public
showed little interest in wearing seat
belts even though Nash Motors installed
seat belts in 40 000 cars only about 1
000 of them were actually used by
drivers when Ford led a marketing
campaign in 1955 to promote seat belts
and other safety options they Too Faced
public backlash however in the 1950s
resistance began to ebb away with a new
innovation by Swedish engineer Niels
Bolin Bolin first began developing
features for Saab including an injection
seats bus was then poached by the
president of Volvo he experimented with
several designs including a seat belt
that fastened between the legs an idea
which 95 of my audience just gasped at
he ultimately settled on the design
we're familiar with today the
three-point harness this setup more
evenly distributes the forces of a crash
across the shoulders and hips
Olin was able to prove the effectiveness
of this design and received the U.S
patent force in 1962 but rather than
profit from it the design was released
for free Paving the way for a new and
Incredibly important safety feature
while certain elements of the seat belt
have been modified and improved over
time the main design Remains the Same we
need a way for the strap itself to wind
and unwind under normal circumstances
allowing passengers to easily move
around and take it on and off without
adjusting its size for different
passengers and drivers we have all
experienced that annoying phenomenon
where you try to put on a seat belt too
quickly causing it to jam this happens
as a result of a false alarm in the seat
belt mechanism this mechanism it has a
number of components the simplest being
the spiral torsion spring when the seat
belt is Unwound it spins a cylinder at
the center of this torsion spring
pulling the spring into the center into
a compressed State storing energy that
can retract the seat belt tightly
against your body once the belt buckle
is locked into the Buckle socket this
mechanism is usually attached to one
side of the webbing spool while the
locking mechanism that will prevent the
spool from being Unwound at all during a
crash is located on the other side for
this mechanism to work we need a way to
detect a crash extremely quickly one
kind of locking mechanism reacts to the
momentum change of the vehicle just as
our bodies want to continue moving
forward in a crash a weighted mechanism
inside the seat belt will too first we
need a ratchet gear like this attached
to the same cylinder at the center of
our torsion spring this gear will be
engaged to prevent rotation now we need
a mechanism that can engage this gear
when the car decelerates this can be
done with a weighted pendulum when the
car decelerates this weight will swing
forward causing its opposite end to jam
into the ratchet preventing it from
rotating any further like any good
safety mechanism there is a redundancy
in its design being backed up by another
locking mechanism one you can test
without crashing your car by tucking on
your seatbelt hard enough this mechanism
will activate as it depends on
centrifugal force to activate two
weighted levers are attached to the
central spool when the central spool
unwinds at a normal speed these levers
do not create enough Force to overcome
the force of a spring that pushes them
towards the center but if the webbing
comes out in a sudden jerk the
centrifugal force exceeds the force of
the spring and the levers push outwards
engaging the Locking teeth and
preventing further rotation there is
another safety mechanism added to make
seat belts even safer when driving we
often slump forward slightly leaving
slack between our body and the seas in
the event of a crash it's best if we are
tightly held against the Seas so there
is a mechanism within the seat belts
that actually forcefully pulls us
against the seat during a crash this
mechanism is fired electronically by the
same sensor that initiates the explosion
that expands airbags this mechanism is
also fired by an explosive charge it's
called the pre-tensioner a chamber at
the bottom of the device has two
electrodes an igniter material and a
piston when the car's Central processor
detects the Collision it applies an
electric current that ignites the
explosive and the sudden burst of
pressure forces a mechanism to actuase
to quickly retract the seat belt and
pull the passenger tightly against the
Seas finally the seat belt has several
mechanisms built in to reduce the risk
of seat belt syndrome injuries some
webbings have a fold sewn into them with
stitches that will break when a set
amount of force is applied allowing the
person to move forward a little bit more
there is also the torsion bar a length
of metal attack to the rotating spool
this torsion barrier is designed to
twist and absorb some of the forests
from a crash instead of allowing the
energy to be transferred to the
passenger's body
despite the clear benefits of this
three-point belt system it took decades
before the use of seat belts really
became widespread although Wisconsin was
the first state to require all carers to
install seat belts in the front in 1961
it wasn't until 1984 that another state
New York required passengers to actually
wear them I remember growing up in
Ireland in the 90s and seeing this
change in opinions about seat belts in
real time and I especially remember
moving to Malaysia a country with a
terrible road safety record and where a
friend of mine died because he wasn't
wearing a seatbelt and arguing with
local co-workers who refused to wear
them the national highway traffic safety
administration estimates fifteen
thousand lives are saved by seat belts
every year in the us alone so please put
on your seatbelt they do save lives
of course there are plenty of other
devices helping to make Cara safer we
have front and side airbags crumple
zones driver assist and emergency
braking and Volvo is now proposing a
blanket-style seat belt for its
autonomous carriers that would keep
passengers safe and comfortable even
when they're napping but that's still
something of a pipe dream since we're
still a long way from self-driving cars
for now we are stuck with the
three-point harness a simple and cheap
device to keep passengers safe sometimes
Simple Solutions really are the most
effective other times more complicated
Solutions are needed one concept is so
complicated that I struggle to wrap my
head around this I have a basic
understanding of how computers work and
a firm grasp of physics but the physics
of quantum Computing goes right over my
head I wanted to start learning more
about it in preparation for a future
video but my usual method of using
college textbooks was not helping me I
didn't know what I didn't know which
makes asking the right questions really
hard
then I discovered that brilliant has a
new course on Quantum Computing created
in partnership with Quantum Computing
researchers
it took me from the very basics of
quantum Computing starting at a level I
understand with basic logic gates
testing my understanding along the way
and explaining to me the correct answers
in clear understandable terms when I got
something wrong I regularly have to dive
into the deep end of unfamiliar topics
to write the scripts for this Channel
and the most difficult part is usually
knowing what questions to ask but
brilliant removes that challenge with
curated guided courses designed to
gradually level up your knowledge
you can take this course or one of
brilliant's many other courses including
her very own partnered course
by signing up to brilliant's free trial
with the link in the description or by
going to brilliant.org forward slash
real engineering and if you found it
valuable which I'm sure you will you can
continue 20 off the annual premium
subscription
this offer is only available to the
first 500 people to sign up brilliant
teachers with interesting and fun
interactive courses that challenge you
along the way making the learning
process much easier and more rewarding
and they're adding more content monthly
so there's always something new to learn
you can get started for free by clicking
the link on screen right now and the
first 500 people to do so will get 20
off Brilliance annual premium
subscription